So the second part of the Trump Lane Maxwell
story is about what Trump meant by I wish
her well.
Now, I already laid out for you how on Tuesday
at Donald Trump's Corona virus press briefing,
he was asked about the arrest of Julian Maxwell,
the alleged groomer and trafficker of girls
for Jeffrey Epstein.
Trump bizarrely wished her well and then said
he doesn't know anything about the connection
between Prince Andrew and Jeffrey Epstein
in the last segment we focused on showing
you in 2015.
Trump certainly knew about the connection
between Prince Andrew and Jeffrey Epstein.
Let's now talk about I wish her well.
Take a look at this clip.
Just Lane Maxwell is in prison and a lot of
people want to know if she's going to turn
in.
Powerful people.
Know talked in the past.
And you can criticize Bill Clinton's behavior.
I'm wondering, how do you feel that she's
being turn in powerful man?
How do you see that working out?
I don't know.
I haven't really been following it too much.
I just wish her well.
Frankly, I've met her numerous times over
the years, especially since I lived in Palm
Beach, and I guess they lived in Palm Beach.
But I wish her well.
Whatever it is, I don't know the situation
with Prince Andrew.
I just don't know.
Not aware of it.
Now, a lot of people wrote to me saying, isn't
it really weird that Donald Trump asked about
someone accused of horrible crimes?
Right.
Serial sex trafficking and grooming of young
women and girls wishing her well?
That's weird.
Well, of course it's weird, but Donald Trump
is a weird guy.
He has a different moral code than many of
us have.
But there's a different perspective from Donald
Trump's former aide and very brief White House
communications director Anthony Scaramucci,
who tweeted about this and Scaramouch.
He says Trump is wishing her well not to wish
her well.
It's code for her not to talk.
In other words, don't cooperate.
Don't tell investigators what you know about
Trump's activities, possible activities with
Jeffrey Epstein and Scaramouch.
She tweeted in the morning earlier this week,
quote, She has the goods on him.
He is signaling, please don't talk.
Now, of course, it's speculative, but also,
of course, if indeed there's some connection
that involves Donald Trump and Jeffrey Epstein,
there's no shortage of such allegations.
Donald Trump has shown that he is very much
willing to reward people who stay quiet with
either pardons or commuting their sentences.
If you believe that Trump wishing her well
is a signal that she should stay quiet.
There's really an implicit threat there, sort
of like a mafia boss suggesting that the guy
who got arrested hopefully is going to have
good luck.
Right.
Which means don't say a word.
Donald Trump has used similar language to
other associates who have been indicted.
Michael Flynn, Roger Stone, Paul Manafort.
He's talked about wishing them good luck,
wishing them the best, I hope for the best
for them.
So there's a degree of speculation here.
On the other hand, you could say, of course,
that's what Trump is doing.
And it's completely obvious, like there are
on the one hand, there's people saying this
is sort of speculative.
On the other hand, there's people saying clearly
this is what Trump is doing.
And that's exactly what he's signaling to
her by saying, I wish her well.
Now to go back to the beginning and the sort
of bizarre nature of Trump wishing well to
a serial accused child sex trafficker.
Just imagine what would have happened if Barack
Obama was asked about someone who had been
accused of supplying underage girls for people
to sexually assault.
And Obama has said, I wish them well.
Think just for a second about what Fox News
and all right wing media would have done for
days if Barack Obama had done that.
And you remember, you know, this myth of the
liberal media just instantly crumbles before
our very eyes.
So in terms of, you know, do I expect we're
going to get.
Public news of any kind of allegation from
Julian Maxwell about Donald Trump before the
election.
I really don't.
There is a contingent that believes the timing
of this New Zealand Maxwell thing is exactly
so, that in mid-September, late September,
early October, there is just blockbuster allegations
made about Donald Trump and its connection
to Jeffrey Epstein.
Part of why?
I mean, listen, I don't know if there that
there is such a plan.
I actually don't know that it would make a
difference at this point.
Trump was accused before being elected president
by 16, 20 women.
He subsequently in books that came out, that
number went to 30 40 something women who have
accused Trump of different degrees of sexual
assault up to and including rape.
And Trump's approval and his polling started
to suffer when he failed on Corona virus,
when he failed on the economic responds to
Corona virus, when he responded to protests
against police brutality by threatening to
and actually sending in federal troops.
So not only am I not sitting around waiting
for that to happen in terms of Julian Maxwell,
I don't even know that it would make much
of a difference.
I think that the real issues continue to be
the ones that people tell us they are.
If you look at recent polling, the three issues
hurting Trump are virus response, economic
response and response to the George Floyd
protests slash race relations.
I don't even know that this is really what
we need.
More allegations from Julian Maxwell, if she
has them to make.
She should make them and they should be reported
on.
But waiting for that as what's going to knock
Trump out of office, his supporters have shown
they don't care about that.
And I think that that's the approach that
we should have.
You disagree with me?
Let me know.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman.
Also, remember that you can get the daily
every single weekday, Monday through Friday
daily audio podcast for free on any podcast
app that you prefer.
I tunes beautiful Spotify available.
Google Play podcasts have added us the daily
audio podcast typically released at 3:00 p.m.
Eastern every day.
We'll take a quick break and be back after
this.